Okay. I am not saying that Donald Trump will
win reelection in 2020 but I am saying that
the left and Democrats can almost guarantee
it if they keep up some of the antics that
we're seeing right now. Today.
I will present to you an anti playbook for
Democrats for 2020 which I will be talking
about. This is stuff that democrats shouldn't
do. Okay. Let's take a look at the list. First
of all, let Trump set the narrative and this
includes our recent discussions about Twitter.
Yes, Donald Trump often makes racist comments.
There is not a a an election to be won by
having endless debates about how racist we're
Trump's comments. Trump using Twitter and
using the media to set the narrative is a
way that Democrats will lose control of the
2020 campaign and it will help Donald Trump
get reelected every day that Donald Trump's
racist tweets create yet another 24 hour cycle
of debate over how racist it was and I'm not
defending any of what Donald Trump has said
or done is a day that we are not focused on
issues and why people should be voting for
a Democrat for the White House in 2020 instead
of Donald Trump.
Number two, continuing to argue publicly about
impeachment. I've said it before and I will
say it again since I'm summing all all of
these points up today, Democrats need to decide,
are we doing an impeachment inquiry now and
if so do it. Are we waiting and are we going
to do an impeachment inquiry at some point
in the future? Maybe six months from now that
we've determined will be more damaging to
Donald Trump's reelection campaign or, and
if that's the case, shut up for now and do
it in six months. Uh, or number three, are
we going to move on and we're not doing an
impeachment inquiry and we're going to forget
about it and we're just going to try to win
the 2020 election on the issues no matter
what public debate amongst Democrats and infighting
about if, when, how, or whether to start an
impeachment inquiry is not going to help remove
Donald Trump from the White House in 2020
number three debating issues of minor concern
to voters.
I don't want to spend a ton of time on this
one because it really probably deserves its
own segment of, but this also relates to the
idea of spending too much time on losing issues.
The entire part of the last debate about raise
your hands if you will give free healthcare
to undocumented immigrants. There is a very
important philosophical debate to be had around
that. And it is a debate that is basically
happening within the left because the right
for the most part says, no, we're not giving
free healthcare to undocumented immigrants
in the general election. That's a losing issue.
And what I hope we see in the subsequent debates,
the tonight second democratic debate that's
going on this week, the September debate when
it comes to questions about health care or
whatever else, democrats need to take back
the narrative from these a poorly framed questions
by the debate moderators.
It's partially the fault of the debate moderators,
I will admit. And we need to stop sort of
rallying around what in the general election
are going to be losing issues and free healthcare
for undocumented immigrants in the general
election will be a losing issue. And I understand
the merits of it, but this is again, a playbook
for winning not a playbook for being right
philosophically. Okay. Um, there's advice
floating, floating around about Democrats
should focus on just one issue. Democrats
should say there's so much noise out there
and Trump's tweets and the border and taxes
and all this stuff, democrats should focus
on only one issue. I think that is a losing
strategy. Very often you hear that that one
issue should be healthcare Democrats can walk
and Chew Gum at the same time, or at least
they should be able to at least the person
we want to put in the White House should be
able to focusing only on one issue, even if
it is as important an issue as health care
is not a winning strategy and democrats should
not take this one issue approach.
Uh, another, uh, thing that Democrats really
need to not do is allow Donald Trump to divide
the left, the Polosi versus the squad stuff
that we talked about last week. There is a
really healthy and important debate to be
had within the Democratic Party about is this
going to be the party of the center left like
Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden and Nancy Pelosi?
Or is this going to be the party of people
like Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren when
it comes to presidential candidates? And what
is the role of the squad versus Nancy Pelosi?
And sort of figuring that out, allowing Donald
Trump to take advantage of that, to insert
himself in it, to take sides to drive a further
wedge between sides of the Democratic Party.
This is a way to lose the 2020 election and
Democrats need to be aware of how so many
of Donald Trump's actions and the people around
him are designed to divide the left in that
way.
Uh, not understanding how to spend money is
going to be a downfall of the Democrats in
2020 if we don't figure it out. Uh, Donald
Trump is going to pour money into advertising
in the Midwest. The Midwest was the difference
maker Forum in 2016. It was really close.
We need to understand how to spend money.
I would love to get money out of politics
in 2020. There will still be money in politics.
W W democrats need to figure out how to spend
it. Uh, and then also we should not try to
win the election. Trying to change the minds
of Trumpists. You know my thoughts on this
already. This is about turnout. This is about
getting our base out. And by our base, I don't
mean 60 plus year old democratic voters who
have voted for 40 years. That's a different
type of base. I mean people who are clearly
against Donald Trump, but who may not vote,
okay?
You can get 10 of them to vote probably with
less effort than you can change the mind of
one Trumpist. So we are not going to win this
election by changing the minds of Trumpists.
And then the other thing democrats should
not do is ignore voter suppression until November
of 2020 every election cycle. I do this and
I tell you we need to continue talking about
all of the voter suppression tactics throughout
the periods between elections. And I've been
doing it to the extent that I have things
to talk about and there are things to talk
about if we wait until you know, October,
November of 2020 to try to sort that out,
they will cheat. Okay? We have to turn out
new voters in a large enough way to overwhelm
the rights efforts to cheat while simultaneously
fighting the reductions in voting hours, fighting
all sorts of voter purges that are going on
and everything else that we've been talking
about relating to voting machines and voting
machine lobbyists and foreign, uh, uh, interference
in elections and Mitch McConnell's complete
lack of interest or willingness to participate
in stopping that interference.
We've got to deal with that and we also need
to make sure that we get the vote out to such
a degree that we can overwhelm the efforts
to cheat that the right we'll employ if something
is missing from this anti playbook for 2020
Democrats. Um, let me know. I guess I should
add, don't run to the middle. Right. And I
maybe that that's sort of, it's so obvious
that it didn't even occur to me to put it
on the list. But we've talked about this before.
Democrats right now should not be running
a centrist platform. We needed to actually
run a platform that represents the progressive
values that matter and that are important.
Let me know if something's missing from the
list.